[Music]
foreign
County is located right in between
Cleveland and Columbus Ohio and I would
say I was first aware of period poverty
in Richland County throughout covid-19
the pandemic period poverty is a lack of
access to resources as well as education
related to menstrual health or periods I
was quite surprised when I realized that
here in the United States period poverty
is actually a massive issue one in four
K-12 students reported not having access
to period products or the ability to buy
those period products and also our
education system is not preparing
you know our students are our future
leaders to even know what a tampon or
pet is or how to use it or what your
menstrual cycle is menstruation wasn't
something I really learned about in
school
at all we did that whole like separate
the boys and girls talk about puberty or
whatever and it was like you get a
period
yay and that was it usually people are
grossed out by the fact like talking
about periods they think it's gross but
it needs to be normalized so in Richland
County the way that we are addressing
period poverty is by collaborating with
our local library system to ensure that
every single public restroom not only in
the library branches but also here at
the public health department are fully
stocked with free pants and tampons so
if anybody is going through a menstrual
cycle they can simply just come into any
of the library branches or the health
department and stock up on whatever they
need libraries are a great place for
these dispensers because libraries are a
place that people feel comfortable
coming to it's a non-judgmental place to
come to it's a place where you can find
all sorts of resources so this is just
one more resource and what I'd like to
do is to work with Julie and her team to
provide education to our
Librarians are all about equity passing
out free
really makes everybody feel good however
we saw this as an opportunity to really
educate and Empower people to learn more
about menstrual health and just their
health in general so nnlm has been a
huge help with this effort oftentimes
menstrual Health has a stigma associated
with it and unless people are receiving
trustworthy
information they may not be able to make
an informed Health decision this
population that we are targeting are
medically underserved so they need
health literacy and they need
information so if we're providing the
education and awareness we're providing
a long-term lasting impact on them as
well it doesn't have to just be Richland
County other communities can replicate
this model so this is a pilot program
definitely for something bigger we want
to make sure that menstrual Equity is
available for all so we're starting here
in Richland County and hopefully soon we
will be all throughout the state of Ohio
and I cannot wait to see other libraries
across the country do this same project
as well